ضمن فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نرصد
اهم ردود الفعل على قرار اليابان تصريف
المياه المعالجه من محطه فوكوشيما النوويه
في مياه المحيط الهادئ اعتبارا من يوم
الخميس المقبل فما القصه اولا تقع محطه
توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه النوويه فوكوشيما
دايتشي في بلده اوكوما التابعه لمقاطعه
فوكوشيما الواقعه شرقيه اليابان المحطه
عباره عن مجمع يتالف من سته مفاعلات نوويه
تعمل بالماء الخفيف وتولد طاقه كهربائيه
مقدارها
4.7 جيجا وات الامر الذي يجعلها واحده من
اكبر 25 منتج للطاقه الكهربائيه في العالم
في الحادي عشر من مارس اذار وقبل 12 عاما
وقع زلزال في اليابان زلزال كبير بقوه 8
درجات ف9 على مقياس رختر ادى هذا الزلزال
وقتها الى مشاكل تقنيه ادت الى ارتفاع ضغط
المفاعل ونتج عنه زياده في النشاط
الاشعاعي وبسبب ذلك امرت السلطات
اليابانيه باجلاء السكان ضمن نطاق بلغ 10
كيلومترات منذ ذلك الحين تبحث اليابان عن
طريقه لتصريف المياه من المحطه النوويه
وتضع الخطط التي يراقبها الجيران
والمنظمات الدوليه لضمان عدم حدوث كارثه
نوويه في المنطقه بسبب تسرب تلك المياه
الملوثه وبالتالي الاضرار بالبشر هذا
القرار اثار ردود فعل اغلبها رافضه من
الدول المجاوره على الرغم من تاكيد طوكيو
ان عمليه تصريف المياه المعالجه من محطه
فوكوشيما في البحر ستستمر لسنوات ولن تكون
لها اي عواقب على البيئه او صحه
الانسان الخارجيه الصينيه استدعت السفير
الياباني في بيجين على خلفيه هذا القرار
وحثت الحكومه اليابانيه على الغاء الخطه
التي تعتزم وتنفيذها في المحيط الهادف
بيجين اضافت كذلك انها ستتخذ الاجراءات
الضروريه لضمان البيئه البحريه وسلامه
الغذاء والصحه العامه وفق تعبير المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه من جانبها قالت سلطات هونغ
كونج انها ستفرض قيودا على واردات الاغذيه
من اليابان وفي المقابل اعتبرت كوريا
الجنوبيه ان خطه اليابان ليست فيها مشاكل
علميه او فنيه للمزيد ينضم الينا من اتناء
البروفيسور مارك فاتس باتريك وهو كبير
الباحثين في قضايا الامن النووي بالمعهد
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه وهو كذلك
المبعوث الامريكي السابق للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اهلا وسهلا بك
بروفيسور هذه الضجه والخوف هل له فعلا ما
يبرره
كلا هذه المخاوف غير مبرره ابدا هذه
المخاوف هي
محض خطابات سياسيه من قبل المسؤولين
الصينيين الذين يودون ان يستحدث مشكلات
سياسيه مع اليابان ان الخطه القاضيه
بتصريف هذه المياه الملوثه درست بشكل دقيق
من للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه والتي
قررت انه من الامن و تلتزم اليابان
بالمعايير الدوليه في هذا التصريف هي فعلا
الوكاله وافقت على ذلك بل وتعهدت بنشر
تقارير دوريه حول سير العمليه لطمانه هل
هذا كفيل بتهدئه
الانفس الح دقيقه بكل تاكيد يمكن ان يكون
هذا كافيا
للتهدئه ولكن نعرفوا انه عندما تووا بعض
البلدان ان تستحدث مشكله سياسيه تقوم بذلك
ولكن هناك حقيقه اساسيه يجب ان نشير اليها
ان المحطات محطات الطاقه في الصين وكوريا
الجنوبيه صرفت مياه ملوثه في المحيط
وقاموا بذلك اربع
مرات مستويات تركز من التريتيوم اربع مرات
اكثر من مستويات التركز في هذه المياه
اليابانيه وبالتالي يجب النظر في تاريخ
البلدان على المستوى المحلي في الصين وفي
كوريا الجنوبيه بالاضافه الى مقارنه ذلك
مع الدراسات على مستوى الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه لاتخاذ القرارم ذلك
بروفيسور منظمه جرين بيس مثلا اعتبرت الحل
الذي لجات اليه طوكيو حل خاطئ هل هل هناك
فعلا بعض المخاطر وان كانت
محدوده لقد فكرت بهذا الموضوع وفكرت بما
هيه المخاطر المحتمله حيث ان المياه عولجت
بشكل كبير وخففت بشكل اساسي
وسوف ايضا تصرف بعد ذلك في المحيط اذا ما
كان هناك اي مشاكل مرتبطه بالزلازل سوف
توقف اليابان هذه العمليه وتخزن المياه في
خزانات لذلك لا ارى حقيقه لا ارى المخاطر
اعتقد ان المنظمات من مثل جرين بيس لديها
معايير مثال بين مزدوجين غير ممكنه في
العالم الذي نعيش فيه اليوم الصين وهونج
كونج
مثلا قاموا بحظر فوري على المنتجات
البحريه الاتيه من من عشر مناطق في
اليابان هل هناك اي خطر ولو كان محدودا
اقول مره اخرى على الثروه السمكيه مثلا في
تلك
المنطقه كلا كلا ما من مخاطر في الحقيقه
ما من مخاطر باستهلاك الاسماك من تلك
المنطقه بالنسبه الى مستويات التريتيوم
سوف يكون هناك تركز اكبر في الوز
بالمقارنه مع السمك اذا موزه واحده فيها
تركز اكبر من تريتيوم من الاسماك في
فوكوشيما وهذا امر
نتحدث عن مستويات اقل بكثير بالمقارنه مع
الموز على سبيل المثال ومع ذلك بروفيسور
طوكيو خائفه على سمعتها العالميه في مجال
الصيد البحري حتى انها خصصت 190 مليون
دولار ل يورو عفوا لمعالجه اي اثار تتعلق
بالسمعه هل هل من السهل ان تقوم
بذلك
نعم بالفعل لقد وضعتم الاصبع على الجرح
الا وهو السمعه هذه هي المشكله الاساسيه
بالنسبه الى اليابان وكما تفضلتم تركز
اليابان من خلال تخصيص موارد جمه لمحاوله
تحسين
صورتها في
مجال السمك والمنتجات البحريه ولكن ذلك
صعب عندما يكون لدى اليابان خصو في الصين
على سبيل المثال يقومون بهذه التصريحات
شكرا لضيفنا من اثنا البروفيسور مارك فيتس
باتريك كبير الباحثين في قضايا الامن
النووي شكرا جزيلا لك